foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone good evening I
hope you're all having a good next
session so far
I want to start off by saying thank you
for making the next 45 minutes to spend
time with us
and with that my name is Rohit Puri and
with me I have srinath padmanabun today
and we are both part of the Google Cloud
platform team at Google and I'd like to
introduce yourself first thanks Rohit
thanks everyone for joining us today
hopefully you find this session useful
and we will of course stay on for any
questions you have after the session my
name is srinath I'm a product manager
here at Google cloud and I've been at
Google Cloud for just under six years
six years next month and uh so I started
off my career as a developer writing CC
plus plus code more than 15 years ago
and then it's been a long while so I
came full circle and I said okay I want
to start building tools that help
developers be more efficient and go
faster and so that's a little bit about
me and where I am today I work in the
devtools.org and help build tools to
help developers go faster awesome thank
you so I'm going to date myself here
given what she and I just talked about
I've been in this space for about 25
plus years online engineering PM the
bias Marketing sales done the whole
shebang
um and I had an epiphany about a couple
weeks back when I was talking to srinath
when I started my career 25 years back
the technology was the most interesting
place to be but there were these
conversations around me about student
loan paying for college kids going to
college and I had no interest in them 25
years later I am those people now
because I have kids going to college
technology and they're all ramping up as
well right with that in mind a quick
show of hands how many here have worked
with a cloud platform in development
and keep your hand up if that's been gcp
Google Cloud platform
very cool exciting so with the changes
in the technology landscape I'm sure the
audience here has been through that as
well in the last say 20 years the change
of pace the pace of change in technology
has been fast and it's only gone faster
right with that businesses people
organizations all need to keep up to
speed with that technology to make the
best use of it it is exciting but
sometimes can get challenging as well
with that in mind today's 45 minutes is
focused on you saw the Innovations today
at our keynote on cloud and AI right in
parallel is how do I ramp up keep up to
speed and make the best use of this
technology in a quick fast way so we
spend a few minutes talking about the
introduction and overview of what we'll
cover we'll go through the learning
cycle and what it takes from a
developer's perspective to sort of be up
to speed and take the burst out of the
technology uh shinati will do a
walkthrough of all the things that
Google has invested in to make it easier
for people to adopt the technology get
up to speed and learn about it and we'll
end the day with pointers to some
Hands-On areas that we found useful and
we are investing in to make it easier
for you to learn and get started with
the Google cloud and AI Technologies
right with that in mind
if you look at the cloud and AI space
the speed of innovation has been so fast
like I remember initially way back when
you started off the adoption technology
was done in CDs you get the CD you get a
learning path with it and you ramp up
here all the time in the world now VR
technology goes the click of a button so
the learning adoption and the expected
results from that are also expected at
that pace that we are today right do you
want anything today yeah and and to that
point even if you go back a few years
anything you needed to learn anything
you were getting started with the place
to go to would have been to a search
engine you go to Google you search for
it and I still remember the jokes about
how people used to say oh you know
searching is a skill and it still is
like oftentimes two people searching for
the same thing one may end up with
better results than the other and now
with all of these AI tools and
capabilities available like Bard you can
go and have an AI tool do that search
for you and potentially come up with
what most people have found useful in
that space so it's like even over the
course of every year things are getting
better and easier and faster for people
to get started and get going and the key
aspect for that and I'm sure you guys
have experience as well is when you want
to learn a new technology you'll learn
up to speed there are learning paths you
need certifications you need collateral
to go and get Hands-On with it right so
there's a whole plethora of artifacts
that need to follow to make the
technology useful and get ramped up then
the last piece is templates and jump
start so you ramped up you've learned
about it but now you want to get
productive and show Roi how do you go
start doing that you need templates and
jumpstarts to do that and as you learn a
new technology you build your own
templates sort of deploy things faster
and quicker right with that in mind I'd
like to share a quick survey that we
sort of uh did this last year one was
from
an online learning experience where they
went and serve it people saying if
you're this age group or this technology
what are your learning preferences and
modalities and all that so 80 now go to
online resources to learn right and the
biggest challenge we sort of heard back
from that survey was the initial bump of
getting familiar with the technology the
language or the stack that you're going
to work with right with that in mind
as a developer it's more and more
sort of critical for us to go through
the cycle a new technology comes out you
get started you expect to get productive
with it start deploying stuff and then
show results right within that cycle
Google is investing into the areas of
learning paths tools and then you saw a
demo this morning at the keynote about
how you can use Ai and do AI to sort of
help you with that right one of the key
things I can share an experiences is I
started my journey in developer support
and escalation engineer and when a
customer calls you the problem something
is broken you need to learn something
about something new you go asking
someone in the next cubicle or someone
else to refine the solutions for that
right and with the Advent of AI and do
it AI you have that personal sort of
help which collates that say tribal
knowledge for you right with that in
mind I'll hand it over to srinath to
sort of walk us through these three
areas awesome so
I'm going to do a few different things
today I'm going to talk about as a
developer especially if you're starting
with Google Cloud there are a plethora
of tools that are available for you that
can help make your onboarding and your
productivity Journey much easier so I'm
gonna talk very briefly about a few of
those and we'll see some of those in a
demo
um so to get started what are some of
these tools right so as a developer if
you were to come and ask me what are the
things I should familiarize with most
from a tools perspective these would
potentially be three of the things that
I would point out to so first off you
have Google cloud CLI so what is Google
Cloud CLI Google Cloud CLI is a command
line tool that you can install on your
laptop and it's going to let you perform
most of your Google Cloud Resource
Management type of operations as well as
your authentication and things like that
right from a CLI
um I definitely recommend all of you
especially if you're new to Google cloud
and learning to go take a look at our
console familiarize yourself with
products because obviously Day Zero when
you're getting started there's going to
be a lot more information there there's
going to be a lot more detailed about
how you can go and do things what
different options are what they mean and
all of that but once you get to that
base level of productivity and you're
going into your day to day three of
actually developing having a tool like
Google Cloud CLI can really help you do
these things a lot faster and one other
quick example I want to point out is
even going back to the stack Overflow
survey and like even research we've done
internally at Google but also in
conversations I've had with developers
and customers right oftentimes majority
of developers spell and I'm sure most of
you know this right like developers
spend a big bulk of their time in the
IDE
now every time you have to context
switch out of that there is a cost to it
so most developers spend a majority for
sure of their time in the IDE and they
want to see how they can get help
without contact switching out and with
Google Cloud CLI it lets you do a lot of
these operations that you need to
without having to context switch out and
context switch back in the second one is
the Google Cloud SDK so we have sdks
which are client libraries for your
available across most of the popular
languages and these will help you
programmatically interact with products
and I've specifically chosen cloud
storage just as an example for today
we're going to see that in a few
different ways in the demo that I'm
going to do in a bit
and the last one is cloud code so I'm
not sure how many of you are familiar
with Cloud code actually let me do
another quick informal poll how many of
you have heard of cloud code okay
um so one thing I would recommend is
especially if you're in your IDE go to
the marketplace and look up Google Cloud
code we are Google Cloud code is
available on Visual Studio code it's
available on the IntelliJ jetbrain Suite
of Ides as well and it lets you do a few
different things first off it makes it
easier for you to pull in API samples
learn about things and to really write
code to work with gcp it lets you do
your inner Dev Loop much more easily
whenever you're building Cloud
applications and again especially if
you're doing it with gcp but with
respect to deploying this to Containers
or Cloud functions or wherever you're
trying to deploy whatever code you're
right and the third reason I think you
should try out Cloud code is because all
of the things that you are seeing or
you've been seeing with respect to duet
Cloud code is the way that it comes into
the IDE so when you install Cloud code
as a part of that duet is going to get
installed as well and uh so we'll take a
look at that in a minute as well
so
with that as you try to get productive
there's a few things that a few steps
that you can take a few things that you
can do that might help you along in that
Journey first off there's going to be
sample applications Cloud code gives you
a few sample applications especially if
you're new to Google cloud like a Hello
World app and a few other applications
to start with containers Cloud functions
Cloud run so it makes it easy for you to
get started and and of course if you're
going for more complicated things there
is so many open source applications
available where you can get started and
I guess the big key there is as you
continue to work through this you will
come up with your own templates you will
come up with your own sort of getting
started applications that you can then
either like share it with more folks in
your company or like you know at least
help improve your productivity through
those uh Cloud API browser we'll take a
look at it quickly but it's something
that's available through Cloud code that
lets you look at apis enable them look
at code samples and pull them in and
lastly of course bringing in AI power
tools AI power tools can do a lot for
you and especially with the speed at
which this technology is evolving today
it helps you write code and it's getting
better and better at these things so I'm
definitely excited to see what are newer
and more interesting capabilities that
come in over the years
um with that with that
um sorry wrong side
with that I'm going to go through a
quick walkthrough and I'm going to show
you Cloud code and a few of the things
that we talked about
all right there we go so first off when
you do log into your idea today for this
demo I'm just using visual studio code
but when you go to Marketplace and you
search for Google cloud or Cloud code
this is the IDE plugin that will that
you'll be able to install once you
install it there is a walkthrough for
duet AI that lets you see exactly how
you can use and interact with you at AI
but rest assured there's a lot of
sessions over the course of this
conference that's going to a lot more
detail so I'd definitely recommend
looking those up and attending some of
those as well for duet specific
questions
but this in essence on the left is what
you're going to see when you install
Cloud code as I mentioned one of the
things that so so Cloud code is going to
let you do a lot of things so if you go
to the command prompt you're going to be
able to very easily spin up a new
application choose the platform that you
want like I mentioned Cloud run
kubernetes Cloud functions and then
there's also going to be prompts that
let you deploy it into those particular
platforms and in this particular case
what I have done is I have uh
preemptively downloaded a kubernetes
application just to make sure that we're
not uh dealing with internet issues
which luckily we haven't so everything's
great so this is what so what you see
here is a python hello world sample
application that I have downloaded and
um this is going to have everything if
you go and look here it's going to have
everything that you need to very quickly
and easily deploy this application into
gcp now this is where the power of duet
AI comes in so
if you want to write an application like
let's say you as I mentioned I'm going
to be talking about Cloud functions a
little bit today cloud storage a little
bit today but let's say you want to
create a cloud storage bucket what you
can do is you can just have a comment in
there that says write a function to
create a Google Cloud Storage bucket and
you hit Ctrl enter and what device is
going to do is it's going to generate
this code sample and it's going to show
up right there
give me one second let me make sure I'm
good on
yeah I've been having some internet
connectivity issues today which has kind
of which meant this has been a little
bit of Hit and Miss but but anyway we'll
come back to this and take a look at
this momentarily
um
but again you have duet chat here that's
going to let you do the exact same
things as well where you can go and ask
questions and it's going to help you
generate code and do all of those kind
of things
um so so with that we took a quick look
at Cloud code and what cloud code can
give you now um the next thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to talk about a few
other tools that are specifically
learner focused and going to help you
especially if you're getting started
with your journey either in cloud or
even if you're just learning to program
right so one of the partners who we've
been working with on this front is
replit so I'm sure many of you have
heard of replied replit is a great place
to go and learn to code like they have
this course on learning to code in
Python in 100 days which is very popular
and so we've been working with replit
and uh
as a part of this partnership what you
have now is uh as of today morning we
now have some templates available here
in Rapid that you can easily open up and
start interacting with some of these
apis and in this case the exact API that
we've pulled in is uh for storage just
to show you just to continue with that
theme not only that very soon you'll
also be able to from right from the
Google Cloud documentation Pages you'll
be able to open code samples starting
with a few and then over time going to
more samples you can directly click on
one button and open it and wrap it once
you do this replit also has an extension
available that's going to help you
easily authenticate into Google cloud
and once you authenticate into Google
Cloud you will also be able to so all
you do is you say connect it to Google
cloud and it's going to walk you through
a set of steps to authenticate and once
you do that you will be able to run this
API sample and get productive really
really quickly and the last thing I want
to talk about out before handing back to
Rohit is in addition to all of this
there are of course a lot of other tools
out there like for instance Bard you can
go to Bard and what you can also do with
Bard is you can go and search for these
exact same kind of things right like uh
it's a great tool because at the same
time it's going to let you plan your
trips but it's also going to let you uh
write code so there's a lot of these
tools and capabilities that are becoming
available so I definitely recommend that
you all go and try out some of these
tools and this is a great set of things
that you can use to help you get
productive faster and to go faster once
you've started
um
so the one other thing I do want to
mention is so we talked about templates
that are available through Cloud code
through code samples and how you can
improve those templates over time over
time as you get started but another
really great feature or a product in
Google Cloud that's become generally
available at next is our jumpstart
Solutions so what jumpstart Solutions
provide you as you can see on the left
is it takes popular tasks or things that
as a developer you might want to try and
has the entire stack available for you
so that you can click and deploy it with
one touch so that you don't have to go
through figuring out exactly how to get
them all networked get them all working
so it's it's a one-click solution that's
going to let you deploy these
applications and go from zero to having
them up and running in no time
so with that I'm going to hand off to
Rohit and Rohit you you're new to Google
right so why don't you tell us a little
bit about what you've learned as a part
of learning and getting started with
Google Cloud awesome well that sounds
great so I've been in Google about about
just over a year now right and one of
the things that sort of helped me was
like I said before the learning paths
the certifications and the quick starts
right so I'll share a few of those that
sort of helped me through my journey to
get it started
um and I highly recommend folks who
haven't done this to try it there are
more certifications more learning paths
coming out every day so go explore those
that were very helpful to me right
so one of the things that sort of helped
me out was this map here is I want I
came from an application modernization
space so it sort of gives me a guided
way of saying if I wanted the
application modernization what are the
areas that I should look for and what
content should I go and sort of learn
the learning paths and things like that
right there's a plethora of content out
there and this helped me navigate the
directions where I want to take my next
steps in my professional Journey it also
helped me uh I'll show the story is I
have a son who's in high school right
now and he had a project to do for
building a mobile app and I don't know
how many of people here have worked with
xamarin or tools before to build a
cross-platform mobile app and it's a
very long tedious process even though
sort of tooling helps you right with the
document learning path and templates
here we will we were able to build a
floral app talking to the back end in
about say three days so from coming from
zero to get to that these learning plans
and templates really really helped us
get to that place right
the first one that ever helped me was to
getting started with Google Cloud I come
from a background of Microsoft and AWS
Cloud experiences right so gcp was very
new to me so this path really helped me
get started understand what the Hands-On
lab environment inside gcp platform was
how do I get my account set up how do I
start doing through the labs and sort of
spinning things up and trying them out
without any sort of hurdles right it
made it very seamless for me it also had
a few if you look at number seven and
eight sort of similarities between where
I come from and my knowledge of cloud
development on Azure and how related to
what I want to do in gcp so those are
those sort of were very helpful for me
the next thing that has helped me was in
the most recent sort of uh Innovations
that's advancements in generative AI is
I was new to this space right and
personally coming in from outside right
so these sort of learning paths
introduction llm responsible AI
fundamentals helped me sort of ramp up
in this particular space so the first
one helped me get familiar with the gcp
cloud space this one helped me get sort
of ramped up on the generative AI space
and I also wanted to call out there are
seven new AI courses that sort of been
published recently as well I don't know
if you guys have seen this but I thought
I'll put it here these help you
understand
the boat modeling image generation
caption modeling and Architects decoder
which you saw some of the Demos in the
keynote this morning as well so we have
them here I would love for you to sort
of try these out they're very helpful in
my journey so far right uh
building on top of that one of the key
aspects is certifications in today's
thing in a professional career right to
show credibility on the domain knowledge
and things like that so there are the
certifications that we keep building on
we also have a list of certifications
here depending on your domain of
expertise and where you want to go
certification you can explore and sort
of take forward
thank you
foreign